what if and and just bear with me here
what if I pulled up on my app and I
wrote Let's bomb Cuba oh my gosh and
then swiped right in your hypothetical
government that's not a local thing and
everyone said yes we vote to bomb Cube
but like this story from Newsweek you
enjoy my segue there yeah it's good
bombing Cuba an option that needs to be
discussed says Miami mayor no right
got out of there and we we don't want to
bomb Cuba just to discuss I mean I I
don't I don't think we should discuss
bombing Cuba right like airstrikes air
strikes on Cube what's this crazy person
look people are protesting in Cuba and
they're yelling I think they're yelling
what libertad libertad Liberty freedom
and down with dictatorship and things
like that and then you know the
mainstream media is like people are
upset about covert and Cuba
anti-government slogans the
pro-communist people and uh Cube the
Cuban authorities have been I guess
locking people up they blocked the
internet
we got this from VOA Cuban authorities
block access to the internet response to
protests my favorite aspect of the story
is when Brian Selter of CNN tweeted out
this quote where he's like restricting
access to the internet is a move of
dictators and I'm like what does that
say about Joe Biden and Jack Dorsey in
Facebook and you because he's the one
who's gone on and said Don't listen to
Fox News and you know been a defender of
banning and regulating speech on these
platforms so what does it say about all
these people but yeah anyway look people
of Cuba they're fighting back
I don't think we should go bombing them
though but uh bomb who why what is what
is this the Communist bro who are the
who are those uh what is that what does
it mean the president of Cuba the
Communist Party of Cuba what do you mean
so like this guy wants to bomb the the
sitting government of Cuba localized in
one communist building or how do you go
about that seems tricky yeah the US is
like we're gonna surrender and convene a
meeting of all the great Communist Party
leaders in this one building right here
yeah this time and they're like okay and
then yeah
look at this this is funny uh an
interview on Fox with Fox News
this is uh Francis Suarez noted a brief
history of U.S involvement in
overturning foreign leaders his history
mentioned the U.S air strikes in Kosovo
during the 1999 humanitarian crisis are
you suggesting air strikes in Cuba Fox
News anchor Martha McCallum asked what
what I'm suggesting is that is that
option is one that has to be explored
and can it be just simply discarded as
an option that is not on the table
that's why I was answered and there's a
variety of ways the military can do it
wow please expand on those ways yeah
serious I gotta say that I'm curious
because like a lot of people in Miami
are Cuban and are protesting in support
of the Cubans but I I think an airstrike
on Cuba would kill civilians you know
you get those little drones that are
explosive and you fly them through
Windows that's crazy they have those
that's the that's the next I warned
about that back in the day because we
were working on I was working on this
University drone program I actually went
and chose the first drone test site for
the for the for the the government
program on like how to do the research
and I was like before it started I was
talking to a bunch of like government
people and academics because I had done
this drone research
and they were like we we need to get a
better understanding of what drones mean
and I was like
the Drone that we've seen can carry like
a kilogram what happens if that drone
carries an explosive how will you stop
it and they were just like stone-faced
like yeah like it's here now the
technology exists and they were just
like uh maybe we should regulate these
things dude they're gonna make have your
smart dust they're gonna make drones
that are so small smart dust is like
yeah Ben Stewart was talking about it
it's in the roads in Denver well
apparently it's like there's many
sensors like dust sensors that are small
as dust but they're gonna make drones
that size that can like fly into your
inner ear into your brain
yeah I don't know about all that stuff
yeah it's too crazy for reality I know
they do have very small drones that can
fly like insects there was a Kickstarter
there was a there's a Kickstarter Forum
once they're really really cool the
remote control they just they just flap
really weekly in Flight what was that
that crazy drone movie it was like 10
minutes long uh murder drones or
something it was called do you guys know
what I'm talking about oh you gotta see
it if you have a YouTube video it's on
YouTube yeah and it's this like
dystopian this this guy's building
drones like Amazon or whatever he's like
we're gonna transport all your we have
drones everywhere to transfer and then
the drones go haywire and they start
patrolling the city all day every day
drones flying above murdering shooting
at anyone so people are basically
running from building to building a
Black Mirror I've been trying to live
yeah yeah no not the B's the dog ones uh
it's similar man yeah the dogs were
running around hunting people down the
robot dogs oh meaning they had an
episode where there was these B drones
that would like burrow into your Beast
yeah yeah yeah yup bees died to their
place pollen bees with Robo bees and the
robo bees went nuts I don't know what
that has to do with bombing Cuba though
it's the 21st century bombs yeah drone
bombs yeah dude I wonder if they have
like anti-matter bombs yet
yeah I was reading about anti-matter
bombs because like when antimatter comes
into contact with matter it has a 100
energy release so it's extremely
expensive to produce and contain
antimatter because if it comes into
contact with matter it you know boom if
you can change that they put in a
magnetic ring oh okay yeah so it's it's
contained spinning around really fast
and so to make a device I could utilize
that that'd be crazy I'm too low IQ for
this conversation
it's really really powerful explosives
yeah put it mildly yeah yeah really
expensive to produce at this point like
I'm talking trillions like a proton and
a negatron I think I think that good I
think megatrons aren't real yet but we
got a coin negatron and uh electrons and
positrons the positron's real but the
proton and the negatron what is a
negative proton called I don't know
Megatron right anti-proton okay yeah
Megatron's better cooler yeah
cooler yeah but a proton is that a
positron positron's an uh an
anti-electron is a positive oh right
right right okay it's like a proton I
don't know Megatron so this is not very
political anymore this is a great
conversation though I want to talk about
we might go into this more since you're
a wrestler and we've talked about like
uh trans women and wrestling we might go
into this yeah we'll talk about that
it's funny because like we end up
talking about a lot of that stuff in the
in the members only podcast because
that's the stuff you do bans you for
yeah we'll go deep YouTube all right
just like like this the segment we did
yesterday with with Colonel uh West like
I was I was I was mad like this is dark
dark stuff what's happening commenting
that too they were like this is a dark
episode I know it was horrifying people
watch that but we'll we'll we will talk
about that I suppose for now we're
mostly focused on like whether or not we
blow up Cuba yeah so and uh we're just
discussing it yeah there's a lot of
people right now I I imagine people like
John Bolton us and they're like
what stocks
Raytheon just no I don't know Raytheon
got woke did you guys see that no yeah
yeah Raytheon got woke and I think they
did like a pride month thing oh no they
had like a white privilege training
thing
better I'm I'm kind of I'm kind of okay
with that like I I think about these
companies or like the Navy getting
welcomed I'm like no no no no this is
bad this is bad you know get won't go
broke and then the Federal Reserve gets
woken I'm like uh
maybe it's okay I'm okay with this and
then like Raytheon I'm like oh do I
support this now like it's it's gutting
these these institutions from the inside
out and they're being disintegrated no
because it's fire you know what I mean
and you might have like a shot in freuda
when you're watching fire and golf like
something you know enemy or something
but that's that fire spreads it's so
funny acceleration of sometimes and just
watch it burn from afar but it's it's
you don't even need to be in
acceleration anymore I mean the stuff
they're they're the the Navy
look at those videos of the U.S soldiers
surrendering to Iran and if that doesn't
make your blood boil what was that uh
that whole process I didn't see that
there are a couple of boats they got
surrounded the U.S surrendered they were
like in in Iranian Waters or something I
don't I don't remember the exact details
but I never heard about that the U.S
surrendered a couple small ships and U.S
soldiers are on their knees with their
hands on their heads swap them to the
soldiers
oh they got released oh yeah yeah they
got released by the Iranian
revolutionary guard but uh it's amazing
when we prioritize wokeness our own Navy
our army so what you're saying is that
we could technically bomb Cuba but we're
not going to be able to because we're
super woke now in the military is
completely ineffective wow could you
that's the only reason we don't bomb
Cuba we have a lot of other issues I'm
just imagining that playing with the
rainbow flag on it and black lives
matter in the front dropping rainbow
bombs and the little Middle Eastern
children like yeah oh diversity yeah
well they're Cubans now so right you
know yeah it's still Brown you could
probably put like little prism shards in
the explosive so that when it blows up
it's not red it just looks like a
rainbow glitter yeah we've added 1 000
pounds of glitter to our ordinance I
think this guy this cute this uh
Floridian guys is espousing rhetoric
political rhetoric of nothing's off the
table you know they say this stupid
stuff like nukes are not off the table
in regards to Cuba I'm my neighbor is is
keeping me up at 2AM with this rooster
nukes are not off the table because
they're not that's the point of the
military is you don't want to take that
stuff but then why wouldn't you just
come out and be like no we nukes are off
the table but secretly they're not off
the table like that's better
nukes are never off the table bombs are
never off the table Yeah but I don't I
don't see what's to gain by actually
intervening with Cuba I don't like
communism you know but I just think the
US is a well I mean it's probably good
for the military industrial complex
because they'll be like oh we can screw
up the United States and then create
another massive crisis where we'll get
funding from the government forever
let's do it sees coupons Central Bank
there no they probably just blow up half
of it and then try nation building for
20 years yeah
yeah although cubo's really Cuba is
really close to the US so make it a
state it's not going to be the same as
oh man could you imagine we got
Guantanamo Bay already
yeah Cuba the 51st state Puerto Rico
doesn't cut we have an American Military
Base in Cuba yeah they hate us they're
like get out of here that's so weird
there's McDonald's there they um the
Spanish what was it the Spanish-American
War 1898 I think it was was when it's
the Spanish Empire was controlling Cuba
and America was like we're gonna
liberate Cuba so they did and then Cuba
was free and then Castro came in and
took control so if we were going to
liberate it again
what do we do after that because wasn't
it like him and Shay and and Castro's
like hey check this out I'm gonna
enslave all these people and she was
like ah you won't do it man she's like
you want to bet he's like yeah I'll do
it then he did it they're smart he was
smoking a cigar yeah he'll probably and
then Shea was like you know and then
Shay was like yo guess who I don't like
and then Fidel Castro laughed and he was
like Jay you don't like brown people and
then Shea was like that's right
she was like it wasn't a super racist
yeah super homophobic too um yeah I've
heard that I've heard that a lot is
Communists tend to be like wasn't Marx I
think Che Guevara was too he was that's
what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah even the critical race there is a
racist so there's like a thing about
these leftists so they just really like
being racist I think they're projecting
like especially the white liberals who
are like oh white people are racist you
have to atone for your racism you have
to admit to your racism and then
everyone's looking like they're a weirdo
like what are you talking about I'm not
a racist and they're like yes you are
because I am and I feel bad about it and
I have to apologize for like no you know
go to therapy don't don't project on
everybody else not all white people are
racist I do love it they're like yes you
are because I am it's like that I okay
thank you for admitting that but I'm
going to leave now these are my racist
glasses I see racism everywhere that's
if you're if you're racists that lens is
gonna is gonna make you see it when you
look outside so at a certain point are
we going to be like um Tony shaloob and
Galaxy Quest just laughing at the
absurdity of about to be about about how
we're about to blow up or something yeah
no not me man yeah have you seen Galaxy
Quest uh part of it you what
the greatest genre sci-fi one of the
greatest genres it's got Sigourney
Weaver Ted uh Tim Allen it's got Tony
Shalhoub Tony shaloob and then what's
the guy who played Snape oh it's Alan
Rickman Sam Rockwell Rockwell that is a
great cast and the movie's fantastic but
anyway they end up in the spaceship and
they're just actors and so they're like
freaking out but Tony slope's character
is like all right man I guess like
whatever laugh or cry like they're about
to get blown up and he's just laughing
like yeah laugh or cry man like at a
certain point I just keep my feedback
back bro I got jiggins we got space we
got Tomatoes bro we harvested the
carrots we got like 10 pounds of carrots
dude I can't even eat all these what am
I supposed to do with carrots I don't
even know I grew that many it's gonna be
good carrots too it goes goodness we'll
make juice cake we got jalapenos I was
having last night I don't know how you
guys feel I was having kind of a a
nihilistic night last night do you guys
go through this where kind of like
you're saying just laugh at all the
chaos like well let's just get what I
can out of this before it's all over
that's what our leaders have been doing
for the past 20 years for probably
thousands well you're right a long time
America was functioning we were we
rallied against the Nazis in World War
II we had Drive during all the horrible
interventions we did right with Vietnam
and Korea there was still this American
Elite being like we're gonna go to war
because we're better than you now it's
just like oh the system's broke I'm
gonna steal as much silverware as
possible before the house burns down now
we talked about this before it's like
the Titanic's going down and they're
running room to room grabbing stuff
before they jump on the life raft for
everybody else I know we can fix the
system like we could build a software uh
like a you know decentralized
powered system that's powered by like
vacuum energy or like Fusion Energy
localized that where people can
communicate uncensored but I don't know
if the human
um
Consciousness is is able to do it like I
don't know if humans are just too too
busted as an animal that we can't
function you know sociologically at
scale I wonder about that I know we can
build the technology gotta get that
knurling bro gotta integrate resistance
is futile that's right what's that going
to do though
on the board man no because everybody
will just be the board will it make the
craziest person make everyone else crazy
or we'll make the calmest person make
everyone else everyone will get crazy
that's what I was explaining right in
Star Trek
the Borg was working in unison towards
towards a goal of assimilating more
technology and expanding and whatever
but the reality is if you assimilate if
you've got 10 people and six of them are
psychotic leftists and you assimilate
everybody the collective just becomes
psychotically left it won't function
properly it'll just spaz out and accuse
everyone of racism and then collapse if
you had like nine crazy racists and then
a tenth like really calm Zen Buddha
Master joined would it make the other
guy very calm or would it turn the
Buddha Master races the Buddha Master
wouldn't necessarily become racist but
if they all function in line with the
collective they would all move towards
the crazy racism so the Buddha Master
would be like Oh I'm having crazy
thoughts but he keeps dispensing his
thoughts having no thought and then
eventually the crazy people start to
have less and less thoughts that's how
the board works how do you know because
I watched Star Trek you never been on
the board too they they they look at
Picard when he became the Borg they talk
all about it and seven of nine talks
about it but I'm saying they they lose
their their control their voice becomes
one with the collective and they all
function towards the collective of goal
of course there was the board Queen who
secretly was manipulating the collective
that's that's communism I mean that's
exactly what you can expect to happen so
if there was no Queen
I wonder I wonder if you would as a
strong mind be able to warp the
collective
to bend to your will so to speak for the
for the good of humanity well I think
there's like a I think there's something
like that in Marvel with like Dr Doom
that guy's got like an iron will he's
like a villain but he's my favorite he's
almost like a hero almost like a hero
yeah what was it he used to be part of
the fan he was with them on the ship the
Fantastic Four when they went into space
and then he got what power did he what
power yeah he got like uh I don't know
what like lightning powers and like he
wants to
not destroy Humanity what is his goal
save Humanity so he wants to save
Humanity he's a communist dictator
basically he's authoritarian dictator
who thinks that Humanity will only
survive if he is the one who is in
charge yeah and there's like this famous
comic where he's like confronted by this
great Panther Spirit or whatever and
then he's like I have seen a thousand
futures or whatever and each and every
one humanity is destroyed the only
future I've seen where Humanity survives
is when I'm in charge and then like the
spirit finds that he's like pure of
heart like he actually actually means it
I like him thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time